I did you did the new jack spot in the
black circuit
and man they were looking - it was and
that was high popularity Showtime at the
Apollo when I first started so everybody
couldn't wait to start doing that yeah
yes
man that would sting and all I can do is
sit there and go ahead all right come on
all right guys come on settle down guys
ever get a new jack spot on the new
Negroes please give it to Jay I mean
I'll do the new if you bring me out so
let me do the new jack so Jack's spot is
it initiation yeah I won't get paid I'll
come on the show find out if your
brother's keeper I see I'm gonna go back
to all Panther jokes yeah you can't have
no superheroes up in the hood oh that's
a very pander joke
[Music]
I love that a lot of kids had no idea
what eggplant is no they just like what
is that oh I guess dicks are purple I
guess it makes sense you don't think
that because of that emoji there's kids
at the grocery store seeing that and
being like I thought that was a dick is
that a dick like no it's an eggplant oh
I think they should have made a cucumber
eggplant also comes off a bit racist
quite honestly you could put a lot on
that to smoke that races to me it just
comes off unhealthy it looks engorged
looks like something wrong yeah I like
it
deep purple that's not healthy I take it
as a fiery erection yeah
pressure-packed I think about how a
virgin girl like thinks dicks are coming
in and then sees one circumcised that's
gonna blow her mind
ya know what to do yeah I wonder if
unsolicited dick pics went way down
once that emoji huh Oh investigation
that's the methadone of the dictated it
weaned us if we had the queendom an off
the dick pics that a fire in your own
off here is a stunt right have
you ever sent an unsolicited dick
forever I love that term always cuz I go
I wouldn't have I'd have to be talked
into probably sending it right right I
have to be heavily solicited do they
have it right now we just sound like
responsible firearm owners another shot
I've never shot less something as a
buddy license for it god I'm presenting
and then I'm fire I'll send it out it's
not embarrassment look you're not going
to send a picture unless it's a good
picture anyway I'll send it up my
concern is I'm like if they it's that
it's like I just well they'd have to
really be saying like no I would assume
nobody does want to say yeah I need a
pleading I really do enjoy that I go
alright no I've seen dick photography I
believe in composition sketches you say
you can't take your dicks a vampire it
doesn't show up on photographic that's
right you can't walk through doors
exactly and by the way that's why it's
perfect for the me to era you're a
vampire dick garlic ruins it sparkles in
the Sun
I gotta get out of here before the Sun
comes up a vampire is there a silver in
these condoms
sorry I've werewolf the show no I
have a question about this there's a new
Negroes is that like indicative of
something of like the I mean the show is
obviously gonna be all black comics yes
but what's the new Negroes like there's
there like a tag line to that you you
mean like in history like where's it
come from is that what you're asking
sure or what does it mean particularly
in this like situation here okay glad
you asked it is a reference to a book
from the 20s hundred years ago I guess
you could say damn that's crazy so it
was the book that kind of launched the
Harlem Renaissance and it was an
anthology of different writers right
here on Amazon I just got a bookshelf
yeah you could what make me look smart
yes we'll read it on the subway cover
out different editions of it to use line
them up next to each other hell yeah
sure yeah sure there's the whole
collection yeah Christine once this
threesome app starts rolling for us
we're gonna be crushed and ants with our
book collection and sticks we haven't
read Phil that library books of the
original open tabs that was something we
said was that what we did here yeah the
pants to come with a book in it
yeah we're saying for like four guys in
Brooklyn that walk around it's just the
top of the book coming up the Catcher in
the Rye short leash attached to it as
far as this would just be attached on
the inside of the pocket on the inside
so if you wanted to do a dog leash I'd
probably be more of an add-on we could
do that's you know what I mean it's like
hints of personality coming up jeans
yeah also a we could also do on the
other pocket a passport a passport is
travel but by the way the different
countries passport ooh
listen I'm just spitballing here guys
you got a price up for that yeah you
want a Spanish passport I could get
rough but none of the more dog-eared the
corners yes good I want I wanted to say
that uh you know we were talking before
you guys came in here and like you know
a raging New Jersey racist like DJ Lou
over here assume that he's not he's not
Negroes I'm sorry no he's ignorant me
actually this thought this I thought it
was a turn in some we didn't even think
overly of it I was like oh is that mean
like kind of like black comics but not
like Def Jam quote-unquote comedy and
then and then I thought to myself if
that's the case I thought maybe that's
what it was
I wonder if there's like the Def Jam you
know comic view comics who were kind of
like that sure whatever get if
there's like negativity have you have
you got anybody that didn't kiss here's
what will happen immediately to whoever
doesn't get booked yes who you know it
all even to is gonna be like oh I
like oh I guess I'm too raw up to from
the streets on hip hop for that idea
keeps me up at night that idea of
comedians that I love that I could not
book especially comedians that I wanted
to book that I could not book or just
were unavailable or there's all these
different levels of it of the people
that I wish I could book now to your
point there are some comedians that are
gonna be on the show that have been on
Def Jam and comicview is like a Tony
Roberts like a person that wouldn't make
those those were Tony Roberts I mean I
started in the black circle and he just
wanted the comics said no he's great
didn't matter AG mainstream or black
because I never really saw him out of
the black circuit Tony Roberts I mean
got successful he's funny but I mean
he's just funny doesn't matter or
what circus I'm always curious but he
definitely be considered more like he
does like the shack the shack
well I mean but there's a lot of
comedians that look I hate to be like
funny is funny or whatever the hell but
like you know the thing about Def Jam
and I don't want to disparage Def Jam
but like it was a place where a lot of
comics who did not get that kind of
exposure suddenly could get that kind of
exposure
George Ross man a lot of immediately go
for the white guy
[Laughter]
yes of course
Alaska story together oh yeah no he's
yeah he's great old hippie guy who only
did black rooms yes but in the exact way
if you do comedy for five minutes
yourself you're gonna hate look at look
at rich volume hearing a farm hoodie he
looks like a plainclothes cop to
be my step up watch this when it was
like wah and loved his joke about a
decent proposal to the ends this on I
love no no I'm just saying that like you
know Def Jam kind of became its own
style if you will where it's like there
were a lot of people who did it who and
there was no Def Jam so they could just
do whatever they needed to do and be
whoever they needed to be and then there
were the comedians that kind of came up
that were trying to be Def Jam comics so
that way they could get on that show but
they were trying to get on the show
instead of be the comedian they should
be and so I hope new Negroes is on long
enough that people try to impersonate
the stock hack we've been successful to
do it for sure when I stopped doing just
the black circuit I certainly had to
like adjust how I approached like
writing jokes because III pandered
pretty hard yeah in the black sir that's
like a weird thing but uh when I've seen
a lot of black comics who would murder
in the black scene and then they would
come over and start doing like they
figured out over the in stream room but
they would come over to what they would
call the white rooms but frankly it
would it be the cellar you cross over
and it's just like it was an every night
like the same set kind of thing yeah or
what these guys were really funny dude
just doing the same like seven bits that
they just know like why people laugh at
you know they changed their vernacular
and every it's very odd and I'm like nah
man you don't have to like the Carson
Daly it yeah it's for I think I got a a
white unless you're going to a place
where it would be weird as a black comic
you open in an all-white room there's no
such thing as a white room especially in
New York City so it's everybody but even
if it's a predominantly white no white
person no white crowd in today's day and
age is trying to come over there and
hate on a black like it's it's it's
definitely your game to loot you know I
mean when I was originally in New York
when I started in New York there were
those crowds yeah like Times Square
crowds and you get like the UM there was
some like East East Village shows that I
would do the all-white crowds like
parked in nonsense so not necessarily
barked in they were just too damn cool
so like like anything that wasn't
already the thing that they liked yeah
those were always weird oh I must say if
you're a black comic you're just gonna
kill I'm just saying like no crowd in
New York I think it's gonna not like you
because you're black you know you're not
gonna get like this is already gonna
suck as a white dude if you still if you
get up in a black room there's there is
a good portion of the crowd that's going
like this guy's gonna suck yeah that's
why you got a panda right and then well
at a breakthrough but that's the beauty
of it the fun is now like if I go back
and do I just did chocolate sundaes I
sit out in LA yeah at the Laugh Factory
a couple weeks ago whatever in Atlanta
it's so fun to go back and do like a
like do a black show again because I
don't Panther now but it does it you
realize it doesn't matter it's just your
confidence left
always if you weren't pandering as a
white comic what you were trying to do a
joke you thought they might not like
you're telling it like um it's like
you're getting like a third grader
giving a nervous for bull boy when you
really genuine can go up there and be
like you know if they don't let what's
the world's gonna do is not laugh at it
who gives a like that you'll do
well whatever jokes you do normally
there's no J it takes a long time to get
to that place minute so you have gotten
to that spot sure no you're right out of
the gates that's not a thing wrong
sociopath I'm come out of the gate I
don't give a I mean you're staring
and waiting for the light gulping plenty
of that I remember
Oana I did want to talent shows that
laugh a tree and it was me and the other
white guy that was there I don't wanna
it and throw him under the bus but
he had a real hand renamed and he went
up and bomb Foster wasn't sauce
it was a it was a different dude sauce
would kill ya know this guy ate
it and it sucked me out of being nervous
because I just went up there I was like
hey sorry about that other guy look
there is nothing funny sandbag he ate it
with dead baby jokes like he was like
going aggressive to the point where
you're like and he was like no I'm
saying like that kind of voice too so it
was easy to go be like so sorry about
that well I think we've shown the show
it's my whole my whole career currently
is going on the road and having a
feature act be over-the-top like dirty
and like but in that way works like you
never a dead baby yeah and then
the car he goes you guys got a problem
with that man you came to the wrong show
you guys are gonna really run out of the
room when Jay gets up here with no
semblance of a punchline
I'm telling you tonight I can ad-lib
something about a dead baby
than what you've done up there
stop calling it the problems at all you
got better leave now that's so great did
you guys run into that booking a show if
anyone trying to be super edgy that
you're like you just be an edgy to be
edgy on our show we had that once yes
yes we did but that was a bit we we have
actually not had a lot of people bomb
you know you could say like get no
laughs that did happen once and it was
it was a travesty please release it
no no but as the host of the show you're
watching that and are you kind of like
no I won't stage during our live show oh
I played music for people to walk on and
off to so I'm sitting there like holy so
you're feeling the heat of that
boss stomach never hurts so bad
oh man I can't imagine being on stage
well someone bombs like not being it's
one thing to be ripped apart but it's
one thing to watch like but you
know if someone bombs on the show that's
like the full range of experience like
if you see if everyone's funny that's
like alright that was a good show but if
someone tanks forward then you know how
good the people who are funny actually
are oh man I I'll never know cuz I'll
just watch the video of that tanking
over and oh that's my favorite thing
that a watch it's so horrific allele
anybody taking anybody well here's the
thing if it's a good comic if it's good
comic tanking I watch it for the reasons
of like I mean I've watched Dave Attell
have a set where like the crowd is just
not getting he's not giving my favorite
sets sometimes of his ever and because
the crowd blue they were wrong and he
was just saying funny that was the time
when he got one laugh out of a crowd and
he goes man if that got a laugh here
imagine what it'll do in a room that's
not just full of broken toys he was
imagine when I tell that in a real
comedy club not this basement full of
broken toys that's amazing and I'm like
that's I mean you'll never get
much funnier thing said than that yeah
Kurt Metzger bomb for like 30 minutes
and he couldn't get out of it with the
audience but I mean like me and the rest
of the staff were just so I mean like
but I know I'm talking about the ones
where the person that's not like a
person bombing and scrambling vigorously
because they're not ready to buy it's
awful it's a terrible thing it could
have somebody could have filmed me
eating Amaya I tell the stories of
my worst like eating stories but I
mean my favorite on that one I think it
takes place in Atlanta or something I
mean the guy goes after bombing for a
while he goes you only gonna get me off
stage man I'm from Oakland I've been
through worse than this you only
gonna get me off stage and they go but
he goes you know what I'm gonna go
when he leaves and then the host comes
out and there's like a seven-minute
video it's three minutes to the meeting
where was that three minutes he
reintroduces himself
oh and then he which is bad and then
comes out and starts the same joke that
was tanking before and then he gets all
over YouTube Jay he's like you know like
lawyers can recall cases for like Jay
Jay studied bondage to the point where
he can be like well that is the point in
case a comedian V Club this bomb in
particular this is the way out of it now
I'm gonna see you crowd back but there's
a way to walk out of a bomb with it with
some dignity if just like it's something
about conveying the message that's a guy
we never quite clicked me and you you
know I mean like sure if you you have
it's an unredeemable bomb if when you
walk off you just have the crowd really
has you in a point where you're pissed
off and she just goes like I don't know
man you guys just didn't dig my I
guess because what are you gonna do be
someone else
yeah magically just be a completely
different person know you're you if you
just be you and own you in that
situation what that guy did with the
same exact joke the second time around
no when I was at the stardome uh every
show I bought I heard that place is a
nightmare birmingham alabama i want to
do it but I've just heard nothing
nothing good yeah that was a couple
years ago i bombed every single night I
was headlining it was hilarious to me
that how much they hated me the only
applause I got was after I said all
right I'm gonna go like and I mean they
stay that's the other thing that's way
to clap that you're gonna go when they
stayed well that's if I'm bombing if you
hate me why are you still here Leia walk
out yeah I get mad at the show I would
just flat-out Sasha that before with his
no no you guys I'm the last person you
enjoyed any part of this like you guys
did that's just this is you of them off
and you look at y'all just clean it up
if you guys want to get out of here I've
got to finish this work and get rid of
this bucket of water walk yourself out
but I mean you know to me it's all about
the I guess expectations of what you're
supposed to be right which is the whole
point of a little show that Mike and I
have
you know what I was on top of plugs and
I dropped my I dropped it and I
apologize there's no price Friday
I left grounded plug three prongs the
new Negroes with Baron von and open mike
eagle premiering this Friday 11:00 p.m.
Eastern on Comedy Central watch that
show DVR set it up for the series so you
get all the episodes save five minutes
and you and and rerun to do new and
rerun save ten at a time keep until
manually deleted there you go it's a
bonfire Evo life yeah that's the DVR
instructions from the bonfire walked on
my throat yeah now you can't up now
if you don't watch the show it's a
racist you just wanna watch because the
name it bothered you I like that watch
it or your racism could get books cuz
also that term it's so strange because I
feel like we've kind of left that eight
could you talk about like black rooms or
white rooms it doesn't really exist like
that much anymore though does it
I spot yes well that's a blackity black
ass it's like but what's the age this is
me right this is me I go like black
rooms tend to have older audiences
because those are the audience's that
grew up with a certain style of comedy
and continue to go back to that they
won't experience that same very possible
I'll tell you the I'm just so out of the
scene of it but but I mean I shouldn't
have to be going but there was a time I
mean when we come up from Philly to New
York we could do that we were coming up
trying to get into the mainstream rooms
yeah
we were our night would start going
because it was always least like one or
two a night whether it be some of them
in long island queens brooklyn all over
the place but there was a lot i don't
know if it still exists like that anyway
I feel like there's been a shortage if
that makes any sense I feel like I see
less and less of that you know kind of
at least that that extreme version of it
yeah because a lot of comics that are
coming up just I mean you know how much
comedy there is out there so yeah
they're listening to everybody either
watching everybody and they want to be
in every room I think it's necessary
though that is what bread I mean like
you know Mike Epps yeah you know I mean
Corey Holcomb like those those braids a
comedy that are very raw and very you
know for lack of a better term like from
that world of like Def Jam black comedy
that I think it's needed across the
board they're hilarious
well I
and they're not fun oh no I don't think
you are no I'm just saying what you say
that we have final cut on these videos
no both agreeing there's a shortage of
those that world now I think it might be
it kind of like going away and there's
you I don't think you need everything to
merge there should be a circuit that's
still gonna like that I mean I kind of
cuz I only did a couple black rooms back
of the day when I was here so there'd be
rooms in like Queens and Brooklyn Bronx
that I did and some of them I do okay in
and some of them I wouldn't but then
like it was just kind of like I didn't
know who I needed to be in a sort of
weird way cuz it's a weird thing where
it's like you're fought when you're
following a booty contest well there's
nothing worse there's nothing sounds
difficult yeah I was sorry because I
always felt like my family was
disappointed Thanksgiving anytime I did
bad in the black room I'm like damn I'm
not coming back if I have to fight the
promoters for my money it was a pretty
good week oh you're talking about when
you got paid I'll fight a whole
neighborhood of Crips if they're all
wearing tuxedos
how many gang members would you fight if
they were all wearing tuxedos and inline
roller skates yes this is like a Black
Friday
could you take on 100 gang members if
they were wearing tuxedos in roller
skates in roller skates is that's where
it's tricky because I do they all know
how to roller skate half of them know
how to roller skate 100 is a lot of
people do right but a hot but 50 of them
don't get a post down 50 other more like
me and roller skates where I'd be
holding onto a wall and hoping someone
would bring me a chair so I can get out
of these roller skates but here's the
thing that 50 people are somewhere
between that and just not knowing how
here's also what you're not thinking
about when you trip the person on the
roller skate there on the ground that
can grab you still yeah you could shoot
from the ground too yeah the ISTEP also
you got smashed grapes you just be
high I would go down on the
ground one knee bent yeah you know okay
what's that called a pistol I would go
down like that and then and just like
spin around just like sweep anyone who
gets in the
they're on rollerskates dude they're
gonna go down I think they can skate
around you then skate in and what are
thinking inside that stick what how do i
instill confidence inside of you you can
beat people up if you stack the odds in
your favor tan because it's not tuxedos
and they're on roller skates hundred
hundred is a realistic J you're being
out of here I'd say 150 for myself and
I'm telling you I'm not a skilled
fighter you think you can be put in a
room with a hundred blind people and
beat them all yes I'll start banging
them into each other man everybody's
getting head clunks oh dude I bet
there's a blind guy that just cleans
your clock one guy I don't even think
like I swear to you I don't think I'm
tough I don't know how particularly
strong I am I run out of breath easily
all these things are true but in my head
my pictures they're gonna be the shadows
what if they turn off of the lights and
then they bring you to the urinal you
know blind people yeah I just think I
went to that place to eat in the dark
recently hey did your yeah it's just
hand jobs the whole time right that was
my guess I went with Ari so of course
but I assumed I said it I said if I was
in the place with Christine I said this
in the air yeah there's I'd be furious
if she didn't at least try to jerk me
off my finger or summary sheets to can
tire me with a titty out but you have
why wouldn't you that's the only time
you'll ever be able to say you ain't
dinner in a public restaurant definitely
pull my pants around my ankles and just
eat dinner yeah I took your Tussey on
the wooden seat
you just only really knows you hear the
clanking around my belt he's out yeah
so you're saying a hundred blind people
in a dark room now I know if I can't see
I know I can't
how about they know I understand I
cannot there's there's a there is a
light switch mm-hmm it's a king of the
hill there's a light switch where you
can turn on the light you turn on the
light
you're some up but the
light off you're in their world I still
feel like blind people got it no switch
voice which yeah they have their sticks
yes and you know hurt each other more
than if they swing though you're not
doing that and also there's there's four
light switches on each wall right on one
on each wall and you can protect it so
there's a hundred people they can put
like 20 people guarding that light
switch and turn off the lights you got
to fight your way to a light switch you
turn it on I don't think I've been lead
up three if I switch if I have to do
right away is bull through the blind to
get to a light switch house with John
bitch it's on send all your blind no but
I'm saying they got they can just turn
it back off again if one gets by you and
you're not defending it they can just
turn off the lights now you gotta leave
the lights permanently alternate that's
it's unrealistic they'll turn it off the
second I turn on every time it'll never
be on with four light switches that are
being protected by twenty five that's
the blind people in the dark if that's
how they split up if that is their
strategy than yes maybe I'll do is I'll
fight to gain complete control of one
light switch so I just got a knocking
out 20 blind yeah it probably do that in
the dark you start in the dark yeah yeah
you're born in the dark you started I
mean I'm going yeah I'm fighting for my
life in there so yeah I'm gonna give
everything I have and by the way you do
not you know you do not get a cane only
they get came it came they have canes
yeah okay first one's giving that cane
buddy I'm saying that that kids coming
out of the hand first guy I'm thinking
well it's got a tennis ball on the end -
I want one of those kinds yeah we really
some torque on it yeah swing it around
it's gonna be a wiffle ball bat
fill with newspaper what if I could pick
one weapon to have in that situation a
football bat full of newspaper or sock
with pennies in it too much torque
that's got too much give you have to
really time out it's too whippy around
the heavy-ass wiffle ball bat oh it's
like white concrete dude you can kill a
person I'll tell you this I'll go just
aluminum Easton I didn't know you were I
didn't know you were a psychopath I
thought we were trying to clear try to
clear a room oblige people I'll do a
machete on that same room in the dark
completely and I'm just going low with
the machete
I'm just taking everybody shins everyone
will be afraid to get close if you think
you might get your shins sliced again or
that he's coming with drop kicks do you
always wonder about that like when the
day comes like do we eat the blind
people know who are we the fat deaf I
want to say six my I think the people
you immediately go dibs for or my
600-pound life people oh yeah oh yeah we
gotta I don't want that meat no we got
to be those people rich it's gonna be
salty it's gonna be salted natural
flavor I bet it fires up not only that
but oh my god I tell you what you had it
you haven't had a gun steak until you've
had my until you've had my
great-grandmother prepare some gun steak
but here's the thing is it has to be if
you're gonna do a 600-pound life it has
to be a festivity meal because you kill
that it goes bad real quick it goes bad
real quick so you got to cut that all up
a while
Fupa skewers buddy buddy
oh my god you guys are gonna love my
hanging sodium tip Rocky Mountain
something or other yeah my mom convinced
me that Rocky Mountain Oysters were
chicken nuggets and it turned out to be
bowls you tried one yep and you ate a
bowls ball I know I told you that's like
this yeah Ricky wouldn't eat these do
come on
no man that meats been around for so one
on the top level she's fried from the
inside yeah but if you think about look
at that it looks like it looks like
what's the soup with the layer of cheese
cream French onion yeah yeah all that
looks like a French onion where you
could break in and just be delicious
onion soup he sweats butter crack if you
crack the skin it just be like until
it's just rich brothy that's right I
think with you it looks like if you ever
squeeze that's dance you ever squeeze
like like blackheads so you know yeah
and you see they come out it's like a
little like snake that's what I feel
like they sweat like just like thick oh
my that's a big thing look at that girl
elbow dimples you need to get to work
yeah dude oh my god she was so fat or
cheeks were black and blue great that's
gross just start getting open sores
you're so fat
that's unbelievable your skin just
giving up just erupting like a volcano
but who is helping them like it's like a
drug addict it's like a family enabling
a heroin addict so if you're letting
somebody eat themselves into like not
being mobile that's crazy
it is funny words about food those mob
just shut up I'll go to rehab
just get me 16 burgers a loaf a toast
there was an object into food they're
addicted to the chemicals in McDonald's
conspiracy
you're welcome looking for that audio
nightmare yes you can I make grants for
everything we're living our life's
r.kelly style now Oh what you picked up
influence she does I have to use the
bathroom when I go shortly well let me
say first Christine can't wait to hear
the album super fun peeing honor I'm
sure it is all worth it when you get in
that studio I gotta say a lot of these
things I got to make myself do but the
peeing on her is really she's taken to
it I've never really million years think
I'd be good enough at something where I
could pee on a girl you're already
legally you're already think so
you're already a child no you can give
it to child at any playground they let
you pee on them it's about having the
right bargaining chips yeah
we're doing this I know and they always
went out we're talking about yeah this
guy almost came into some dance moves
right yeah I'm on how you seen
background Billy ocean
daddy's weird that that's if someone's
dad someone that open that uh sang back
on Billy ocean yeah yeah there's just a
guy walking around right now where he's
like at a bar you meet him he goes
that's pretty crazy my dad used to sing
with Billy ocean what but even if we see
that when you see the background singers
we went to Fleetwood Mac same thing
you're like they go home was like I'm
sort of in Fleetwood Mac goes it's not
that cool if your friend's mom was the
better thing I bet you'd be like it's
cool we get tickets to go when they're
here it was cool that my friend Zach's
mom was a flight attendant we could get
bunny passes yeah this guy definitely
does yoga or just he's really embracing
being a young vampire finally I'm ready
to see some shrug hats we're gonna do it
just pull that back a few inches buddy
no no I'm just back he's gonna get pull
it back yeah a little more a little more
a little bit more a little bit more a
touch touch more yeah one more there's
various there is dude that is great oh
do your name should be Kyler
West Coast and is great your burns your
burns are hanging out and the
and the top it's great I say you can't
give another inch see right yeah
little right there there is that guy's
got good we Topher mackerel anybody
wasn't leaving out the wrong judge
Romans you got the one curl coming out
buddy it's great to myself customer
Salvation Army it's pretty bad it's like
the way to go it's pretty chill it's
pretty jellies he's already passed he
wasn't using it I was like rolling out
of there put it back into the app my
water oh hi didn't see you come in
there I'm Dan Soder I'm big Jay oakerson
we're from the bonfire on Comedy Central
radio sirius XM 95 make sure you watch
our videos every thursday on comedy
central youtube fresh exclusive visual